[Music]
hello good afternoon everyone
we're so excited to be here today we
know you have a choice of session so
thank you for choosing us and being here
today with us I am James and I work on
Android studio and here with me today is
Jerome he's the tech lead for the build
system in Android studio so we're here
today to talk about one of our favorite
topics which is how to speed up your
Android Gradle builds now slow build
speed is a huge productivity buster it's
kind of like driving down the road and
constantly hitting speed bumps after
speed bumps we've heard you loud and
clear that build speed is critical to
your productivity that's why we've been
focused for the past several quarters on
improving our build speed performance
now to give you some context on why
we're so excited to talk about this
subject today over the past year we've
been hosting a series of developer build
clinics in these build clinics we meet
with developers one on one and they
would come to us and tell us about their
build performance issues now we would
play doctor in these clinics which is
kind of fun and but the most surprising
part of this and this is surprising to
us is that more often than not we would
be able to speed up their development
built by 3 X 4 X sometimes even up to 10
X by applying a simple set of tips and
that set of tips is what we will share
with you today
now our talk today will be structured
into three parts first I'm going to talk
about the tips for improving your
project's development built second
jerome is going to talk to you about how
you can make the most out of the new
Android Gradle plug-in 3.0 that we just
released yesterday and finally he will
wrap up by talking about some tools and
best practices on the how to debug and
profile
your build performance issues so now
let's talk about the tips for speeding
up your builds so what I'm going to show
you is that I'm going to present these
tips to you one at a time and what I'm
also going to do is that I'm also going
to use the Santa tracker project as an
example to show you the impact of each
of these tips now I'm going to apply
these tips one at a time and we'll see
how fast we can get the bill to become
at the end okay okay before we start
though I need to talk to you a little
bit about the center tracker project
because build performance is really
dependent on the project's
characteristics so the center tracker is
organized into nine different modules
including a where module it has about
500 Java files it's pretty resource
heavy with thousands of XML files and
3,500 pngs it uses multi decks no
annotation processors and the final
debug apk is about 60 megabytes so it's
fairly large if you would like to
explore more about this project you can
find it on Google's github account now
for benchmarking of this project I'm
going to show you three sets of numbers
focused on three built scenarios the
first one is simply a full build it's
just a clean assemble debug the second
one is a incremental build with a Java
change
it's a one-line Java change in a method
implementation and the third one is an
incremental build with a resource change
and it's a simple add or remove a string
resource and we can measure the build
times for each of these now just
remember build times are highly
dependent on your projects
characteristics and your build
environment so you may get more or you
may get less out of these tips
that is to say actual results may vary
okay so the first tip is to make sure
you use the latest Android Gradle
plug-in with each release we make a lot
of bug fixes and fix performance issues
as well as introduce new performance
features so you want to make sure you
are able to leverage those now there are
a couple of things to note here first
one is that starting with the plug-in
3.0 we are going to distribute the
plug-in through the new Google's maven
repository that we announced yesterday
so you need to add that maven line at
the top to get the new plugin second is
that the plug-in often require specific
version of build tools as well as
specific versions of Gradle itself so
the easiest way for you to do this is do
the update in Android studio because
they will figure out what it needs and
make sure it's the right combination and
third the 3.0 plug-in is a bit of an
exception because we introduced some
breaking changes so it might requires a
little bit more work on your part to
update we've published a migration guide
and you'll see the link at the end of
the presentation and this was the result
that I got after switching the Santa
tracker project from the old 2.2 plug-in
- 3.0 alpha one now you can see that
immediately we shaved off 25% from the
full build 40% from the incremental Java
change and about 16% for resource change
not that for updating just to the
updating to the latest plug-in now
second tip is to avoid legacy multi
decks now I think most of you know that
if your app exceeds the 64k method
reference limit you will need to use
multi decks but what you may not know is
that if your min SDK version is lower
than 21 and you use multi decks you will
be using what's called legacy multi
decks which is a lot slower to build so
you want to avoid that
now if you usually start your build in
Android studio by hitting the Run button
this doesn't really apply to you because
newer versions of Android studio will
automatically detect the API level of
your connected device or emulator image
and switch to native multi decks is
applicable now but I also know a lot of
you are in the habit of doing your
builds from the command line so if you
want to continue to do that you should
define a new product flavor here for
example I call it development and simply
set your min SDK version to something
that 21 or above and on the command line
now you can call assemble development
debug and you will avoid legacy multi
decks and then these are the results
that I got we shaved another 5 seconds
of the full build a whopping 8 seconds
that's more than 50% of what we had
before and then incremental build for
resource change is about the same as you
would expect
now the third tip here is that you
should disable multi apk generation for
your development build now you do this
typically if I add using the split box
in the DSL multi apk allows you to
define dimensions that you want to
generate multiple SDKs upon the idea
here is that you can tell it to generate
a long dimensions like a bi or density
so that it generates these multiple apks
that are smaller in size now small apks
are great for your release notes but
they aren't that important for your
development bills so if you turn it on
for your development bills you'll be
wasting time packaging and creating
these apks that you're not using now to
disable multi apk generation properly
you can't just disable it in the splits
block because that block is global to
all your build variants so one way you
can do it properly is to define a
property like here here I've defined a
property called death build and I'm just
going to pass
property to Gradle every time I do a
development build and if Gradle sees
that property it will set the splits ABI
and dot density and able to false and
the AP and the multi apk generation will
not happen now if you're using studio
you can also pass this flag through the
compiler options under preferences by
adding - P dev build in this case with
this flag every time Studio does a build
it will also pass the same flag to
Gradle so multi apk generation will not
occur and these are the numbers I got
after disabling multi apk again some
more improvements across the board now
tip 4 is to minimize the set of
resources that you package in your
development build now by default the
build system will include the resources
for all the languages and screen
densities that your app and the
libraries that your app uses define so
if your app supports many different
languages or many different screen
densities then you're actually wasting a
lot of time doing work for no reason
because during development you're only
ever probably going to be using one set
of those resources now to do this you
should use the rest config keyword and
specify the language and the screen
density that you need for your
development build and then you can see
here on the full build we shaved off
another six seconds 24% off the
incremental build in Java change and 21%
for the incremental resource change case
making continuing and mid games next up
is disabling PNG crunching now by
default apt will crunch your pngs
to reduce their size yielding you a
smaller apk
again that's a great thing for your
release apks but not that important for
your development builds so to avoid PNG
crunching you can use the same property
that we define and have add the apt
options and cruncher enable flag to
disable it if Gradle sees that property
defined and again on Gradle whenever you
do a development build you can pass that
property into Gradle to avoid PNG
crunching the other option to avoid PNG
crunching is to convert all your pngs
into web P now web P is up to 25%
smaller so you get a smaller apk to boot
newer versions of Android studio also
supports conversion within the IDE so
you can easily convert your pngs
into web P format now the only thing
that you need to be careful about is the
OS requirement if you're using opaque
web Pease API level 15 and above will
support them but if you have alpha
channels and support transparencies in
your web P then you need API level 18 or
above so that is something to be mindful
of so these are the numbers that I got
after disabling PNG crunching so you can
see we shaved off nine seconds off the
full build here which is pretty
substantial but that's also because the
santur tracker has a ton of PNG in them
so previously we were spending a lot of
time doing that and for the other ones
they didn't really change that much now
here's the kicker when I looked at the
apk size with crunching and without
crunching turns out there was no
difference
turns out Santa tracker was already
using pretty optimal pngs to begin with
and it was just doing PNG crunching for
no reason okay tip six is to use instant
run so instant run was launched in in
Android studio 2.0
since then we have spent a lot of time
improving its reliability the diversion
of instant run that we are launching
with 3.0 is massively different than 2.0
we have removed a lot of hacks that we
made to work around platform limitations
to make things more reliable the
trade-off is instant run will now only
work on API level 21 or above now that
does not mean you can't have your app
min SDK version set to lower it just
means the device that you're running
instant app on need to be 21 or above
we've also tweaked the UI so instead of
having a single instant run button the
button is now separated into a run and
an apply changes button when you hit the
Run button we will try to do a cold swap
and the activity app excuse me will
always restart when you click the apply
changes we will try to do a hot or warm
swap first and that would push changes
directly into the live process now one
thing to note though is that when you
use instant run it makes your lives a
little bit easier because we again
automatically look at the target device
look at its API level and look at the
set of resources it needs and
automatically build the minimal thing
that the target device requires so even
if you didn't define a separate product
flavor you would automatically get some
of the optimizations now and this is the
now these are the numbers that I got
after notice there is we actually
regressed by seven seconds for the full
build the reason for that is that in
order for instant run to work we have to
do extra work to short the AP case and
to do bytecode manipulation to prepare
your app for future hot warm and cold
swaps so that's where the seven seconds
it came from we're working to drive that
number down
now hopefully you you'll see that for
the incremental changes we shaved off
three seconds for each of those cases
hopefully after you do a few of the
incremental changes you would recoup the
initial bill slow down
now tip 7 is a fun one it's to avoid
that you should avoid inadvertent
changes to your project now and the code
shown here is an example of such at
first glance it seems pretty reasonable
the code here is basically just using
the current date time as the version
code for your app which is a reasonable
thing to do because every time you build
you want to have a unique ID so that
when your QA team logs a bug they can
tell you which build it was now the
reason why this is bad is because this
would force your Android manifest to
change at every build even the ones that
you're not distributing to anybody
now Santa Tracker didn't have this
problem but I simulated this by forcing
a manifest change every time and this
was the result so as you can see if I
had that code in my project I would have
added three seconds to my incremental
Java build every time and 3.6 seconds
through my incremental resource change
every time that's huge
and that's time spent for no good reason
now in the previous example you can
easily fix this by putting by again
conditioning the setting of the unique
version code based on the property the
deck build properties that we were using
earlier so in this case if that property
is defined then we set it to a static
value if not we will generate a unique
value now having bad code in your build
script is not the only way to get into
trouble I know a lot of you use crash'
lytx and it's a great product so it must
be safe right well that depends
turns out crash olynyk's by default will
always generate a unique build ID on
every build but they provide a flag for
you to turn this off so you need to be
careful about setting this flag you
should set this flag in your debug build
or development build always update build
ID to false they also supply a different
flag to disable crashlytics altogether
and you can consider using that as well
now tip a is that you should not use
dynamic versions Gradle provides a very
convenient way for you to not tell grado
that hey I want to use the latest
version of this library through this
plus symbol here now it's bad for a
couple of reasons from a performance
perspective that will make Gradle check
for new versions of that library every
24 hours causing your dependency
resolution time to increase now even if
you are ok with that
it's still bad because it makes your
build non-deterministic you bill do a
bill today compared to a bill two weeks
from now you might be building
completely different things because the
libraries have changed underneath of you
so please avoid doing this love tip 9 is
that you should be careful about the
amount of memory you're giving to Gradle
in Android studio when you create a
brand new project by default we will
give Gradle 1.5 gigabytes of memory that
might be a good setting for your project
or it might be a bad setting for your
project we don't really know because it
really depends on the characteristics of
your project so usually tweak this
setting to see what's optimal now
another thing I want to call out is that
in our DSL we have this text options
where we allow you to set the Java max
heap size for the Dex process this made
a lot of sense when Dex was out of
process but since the plug-in 2.1 Dex is
now in process by default so you should
not really set this flag anymore so if
you have it you can just delete it now
the last tip here is that you should
enable the new Gradle cache now if you
were at what's new for a dev tools talk
this morning you might have heard Xavier
talk about this this is a new caching
mechanism from Gradle where you can
cache all the task outputs from every
task now this is different from the tube
from the build cache that we introduced
in Android studio 2.3 which only cached
pre Dex external libraries now this
cache uses the same up-to-date mechanism
but it doesn't only work for the last
build but it works for any previous
build from any location which means it
would really speed up your build when
you switch branches and it will enable
distributed caching now we haven't
because this is so new we haven't fully
taking advantage of it yet
in canary one but we're actively working
on this in 3.0 so our advice to you is
that you should set this to true now
turn it on and through the next several
Canaries previews and eventually stable
you should see progressively improved
performance and these are the numbers
that I got after turning on the build
cache even though we haven't fully taken
advantage of it yet so you can see the
full build actually drop down by seven
seconds and it negated their regressions
that was introduced by instant run and
the incremental build actually got
slightly slower that's something that
we're looking into so here are the
cumulative improvements after applying
all these tips the full build is now
three times faster the incremental Java
build is twelve times faster and the
resource change is also three times
faster
thank you
now here is a summary of all the tips I
have also created a github repo if you
want to be able to reproduce some of
these results and experiment with some
of these tips yourself and that's it for
me thank you James
all right so up to now you've seen
number of tricks and tips to help with
the government now I would like to talk
a little bit more about the more radical
changes you can do with your build to
leverage some of the new feature that
comes with god--all plug-in 3.0 and in
particular I like to talk about the
module multi module projects so we've
had multimodal projects for a long time
that we used to discourage it because we
have quite honestly a lot of issues both
in girdle and in the android plug-in
around scalability as you had more and
more modules the thing was getting
slower and slower so we worked really
hard with daddle to fix this and now we
totally recommend you to go to the multi
module project if that makes sense for
you but what do you have to do so if you
remember or if you have created projects
with Android studio from scratch any
project studio created from template is
a multi-modal project to start with it
just has warm but you can add it it's
ready to be to be multi module to do
that you just need to include a few more
subfolders in your main settings the
girdle and then you can start moving
code from say the app into the liberal
another lip - obviously this sounds very
easy modularity is not easy I can
guarantee it's going to be painful if
you want to do this not painful but it
could be hard and it's not something you
should do over the weekend it's going to
take some time however we're going to
see that it has a lot of improvement
with it so here we have an example of
three modules the app which is importing
the live one which itself is importing
the lip - as you can see the straight
dependency we are using the compile for
figuration to define this and as you do
a cut change before in three zeros that
you're doing some code change in lip -
you would start recompiling leave one
because say your code change may be like
removing a public method so of course we
need to recompile whoever is using that
particular tip - to make sure that you
are not using that method but it will
also
retrigger the compilation of app and
that's because the compiled dependent
see is transitive that means that app
which depends on live one cannot
transitively also depends on leap - just
because live one itself was importing it
- and that's some of the things that is
going to change in 3-0 now the first
thing that gadelle is giving us for free
is compilation avoidance so you don't
have to do anything you're going to get
ripped some of the benefits from it
immediately and what they do is that
they came up with the notion of an avi
when a bi is the application binary
interface in simple terms it means
basically your public methods and fields
anything that can be invoked outside of
your module so you can have an avi
change or you can have a non avi change
depending on whether or not you're using
a public key you're changing a public
API okay now a non avi change has no
impact on consumers if you're changing
the implementation of a method which is
private why should the or even if it's
public actually it is just the
implementation of a method
none of the consumers are going to be
impacted by this change of
implementation so you don't have to
recompile them however obviously if
you're removing a public method or
changing a public method signature this
is an API change this will trigger
consumer modules to be recompiled
okay so far it's pretty simple so let's
look how it looks I have an on a VI
change so something which is private -
live - is being changed
nothing is recompile now I have an avi
change and we are going back to the
original case of three three zeroes
recompilation
I'm changing something which is visible
in lip-to-lip one which is importing it
directly has to be recompiled an app
which is importing it transitively also
has to be recompiled
on it really very annoying because why
would you want to recompile app from
this diagram it seems pretty obvious
that app is not using this tool but the
fact is that because it's declared to
this compiled configuration gradual does
not know if app is using the ability to
to use the leap to interface basically
the compiler
lick the implementation detail of Labuan
which is the lip - to the consumers of
itself that means that now app can see
leave one and Nick - and that's really
really something that needed to be
changed now let's have a look at how
that really ripples into when you have a
really big hairball of modules here
we've got only nine modules that's eight
modules that's pretty simple but so you
have 50 modules and you have one lift
module at the very bottom and you're
making an on a B I shall change so that
you know has to be recompiled
that'sthat's pretty obvious right now
let's switch to the ABI code change
let's say that now we are changing a
public API of that really lift module of
course we're going to recompile it and
then we're going to compile all the
immediate users but because they are
tentatively dependent on each other by
you know when you're gone by the other
ones - and then eventually you can
really compile the app now if you've had
250 modules you're going to recombine
250 modules and that you know when
you've got an SDK a common type of
library this will happen quite a bit so
basically what gadelle realized is that
compile is all wrong and there is no
distinction between oh I want to use
this library as an implementation detail
of my library but by no means should you
be using the API of the API of this
library because you should only be using
the API of my library versus oh yeah I'm
not only about using this API but I'm
offering its API as part of mine as a
composition if you want so say for
instance you are a library and you're
using go over you want to provide your
API it doesn't really mean that you want
your users to use the braava API through
you because that's really nasty when you
think of a time right what about if you
want to remove whoever from your
implementation detail because now you're
using the new JDK collection classes and
guava isn't useful anymore or you can't
because you use in the past to provide
guava as
a transitive dependency of your module
Dib so therefore you can break your
client people can start using guava API
through your module and that's it so
really this compiled dependency was all
wrong and all consumers of the module
consumes all of the quantitative
dependencies which basically was
yielding way too many details about how
you implemented so they came up gadelle
came up with a new way of declaring your
dependency compile is not irrigated and
it's replaced by two new configurations
either API or implementation so you can
see here I'm replacing what I used to
declare X&Y with one declared as an
implementation detail that's
implementation so that means that I'm
consuming lab X as an implementation
detail but none of my users will have
access to it implementation to its API
however I'm also using label Y and I'm
also offering its API as sort of my ID I
am composing over that particular module
okay so this is strict distinction
between the two now
API is basically the equivalent of the
old compiled it's the easy way to go if
you were to do a search and replace by
compile with API it will just work but
we totally not recommend doing this
because again you're going to leak all
your dependencies and after that ID
better would be to use implementation
then you clearly say I'm using an
implementation details as an
implementation detail of my library I'm
using this module and I am NOT going to
leak it to my users okay seems pretty
easy so in fact you should probably just
do a search and replace of all your
compile replace it with the
implementation you will might break
because some users of your library
somewhere was using actually your
dependency you were leaking
the only thing that you would have to do
is that they would have to directly also
declare their dependency on whichever
module they were actually using so it's
a little bit more work but it shouldn't
be so bad now let's look how it looks
like again if you do an on ABI change
nothing happens your recon you're
changing lead to libel 1 and other not
be compiled no change here but if you
switch to the API change this was what
we used to have now ABI
with an ABI change app is not be
compiled any longer only live one will
be recompiled because leap2 is not
visible to app this may seem to be a
very little small detail but when you
come back to the other two the example I
gave earlier where you had this ABI code
change at the leaf module you remember I
was compiling obviously the module that
changes you're still going to recompile
all the modules that import it directly
but it could stop right there it's not
going to reconcile anything else now
here you can see I'm setting about 50%
of recompile of recompilation I'm not
too bad but if you have an application
with 5200 or whatever number of modules
this can be substantial saving ok so it
adds up you come you have compilation
avoidance Plus with API implementation
configurations you're going to get much
faster build I want to talk about one
last final note on modularity when you
have multiple modules gradual can build
them in parallel we've had issues where
you know sometimes the one task has to
run before a number of other attacks
waiting for it to finish can be running
when you do things in parallel you don't
have such issues anymore so this is
really a great advantage to use
multi-core machines when you have
multiple modules having multiple modules
is a great workaround for the lack of
some of the incremental tests as you may
have heard by now and it's something
which is very important Java C task the
task that compiled your Java code into
class files is in theory incremental
however as soon as you start using
annotation processors we have to turn
out the incrementality because some
annotation processes they want to see
the world you know they want to see you
know dagger they want to see all the
injection points are they all satisfied
so even if you change only one class you
have to recompile everything so that the
annotation processors can be fed and our
react appropriately
now if you split this Java C task in
to multiple modules none of them will be
incremental but because there will be
much smaller each of them they were
going to be much faster all right which
why in the cuddle plug-in to provide
some parallelism within a task but
that's difficult and it's limited and
you will never get as much as much
parallelism as if you are using merging
module projects now let's say you've
been very good you followed all of Jim's
states you've tried to understand what's
wrong it feels slow right so what is the
next step for you to understand what can
you do to figure out why is my bill slow
now one thing to realize is that slow
builds are not normal this is not a
reality in which you should be living
let me be very clear a full bill that
takes ten minutes is not normally an
incremental bill that takes almost the
same amount of time as a full build is
even less normal and finally when you
change nothing and you run the build
again and it seems to rerun a number of
tasks but you don't know why because you
change nothing this is clearly not
normal so there are scenarios like this
that you should be looking into and
figuring out do I really have to go
through this maybe there are some stuff
I can do to make things better for me
and we all know that the build is a tax
nobody likes to pay taxes so
understanding the weald is like paying
taxes on taxes I understand that but you
must understand at some level that you
you need to spend some time into it to
invest into understanding where is my
bill being being spent where which task
is taking time so that you can
eventually have a chance to improve it
but what can go wrong like we totally a
third party plugins you have to be very
careful about the third party plug-in to
using some of them are very well written
some of them not so well in correct
organization that's particularly true
for instance when you were coming from
the Eclipse side of things for few years
back where all the source files were in
the salt directory like a IDL C++ and
Java they were all in the same folder so
if you change one it would
trigger all the tasks to be run some
people like to build two to customize
all of the abilities them and sometimes
it goes really really wild and finally
some incorrect setting but you need to
understand and spend some time in the
build system and you know I know this is
not something that you like to do your
app developers but as your project is
growing you must spend some time now
there are tools to help you so that you
spend a minimum amount of time but
before we get into this about that slide
one of the things we repeatedly see over
and over again with people who complain
about their slow build is the do last do
last is that gradual cannot understand
if your task is now incremental or not
because it doesn't know what you're
doing in there do last is bad because
most of the time the object checks will
so fail because you're probably writing
something somewhere at it in the output
directory of the particular task or
you're changing something after the test
run and so basically again not only
please lost so you will rerun your task
every time avoid this type of thing and
one ways you can do that is by writing
your own plugin I know it sounds scary
but believe me it's not that bad you can
write your own plug-in you can put it in
the build source directory which means
that it will be available to all of your
module automatically remember to profile
it a profile code every day and I'm
always surprised and instead of using
the last try to cuss to write a custom
task with proper inputs and outputs so
that Gradle can cache it
cuddle can understand what would make
that task up-to-date or not now
you still don't get it I mean you know
it feels slow and you've been spending
some time on this and it's still slow so
what can you do next thing to do run
with a dry run this will tell you how
much time you're spending in the
configuration this should be a couple of
seconds ten seconds at the best at
maximum if you really have a huge
project if you start spending way too
much time there there's something wrong
some some plug-in somewhere is doing
something wrong and we need to
understand what it is it's not that way
then you should do a - - in full - - in
flow is very useful it will tell you
what tasks are running and why again you
change none of the source code you rerun
a build some tasks are running and you
don't know why the - - info will tell
you exactly why this process manifest
task is running that's because the main
manifest has changed then you have to do
some detective work to figure out who
changed it because obviously you didn't
change it yourself but at least it gives
you a hint next one is the profile a
slightly more complicated tool that will
give you the ability to row to look at
all your tasks and see how much time you
spent in each of them this is very
high-level this is very useful to figure
out that maybe one task is dominating
most of the time we've seen this one
task takes 90% of the time of your build
find out what it is what is it doing
before you report and then for the hard
core there is the gather profiler it's a
tool which is provided by huddle and
it's great it gives you the ability to
profile and to benchmark the profile is
the most interesting one you can
actually generate a profiler information
right from there which you can use to
find berg against us alright so if you
think that you know you've done all your
homework your build is still slow you
don't get it run the profiler give us a
your kit profile information finally go
against us and then we'll stop looking
into why is your build slow much better
than just finding a birthing my build is
slow I don't know why not giving a build
up gradall not giving us any information
this is
not this is not stuff we can act upon
with this we can look into why your
build is know some resources this is
what we've seen today this on Todd
Tucker project Fork look at the
migration guide to on the way to do
optimize your build speed look into the
gradall it's always like you know when
you receive a new GD key you look at the
new things in the GD k when there is a
new Gladwell you should look into what
is the new things in there there's
always a bunch of useful utility that
you can use thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]